[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know no limit now he does not wear the
rest of the stages
we're tier two mechanics a good day
do you want something could you answer a
few questions questions questions it is
a word that you adore let us play a game
if you answer my questions I will answer
yours if it's the only way to get
answers then let's play I am pleased we
will have fun but beware no lies what
name is given the place from where you
come I come from serene a grand city on
the continent of queque really it is
possible that you come from there but I
believe that this is not your land your
turn
this is a delicate question but what do
you know anything about a demon a demon
I think that that is what's the bright
and shiny mind Jake has called the
spirits know there are spirits
everywhere in you and then us in each
three in each spring and there is not
only one I cannot tell you more if you
are not more precise in what you seek
let's try something else
are you on Alman Maui with your land or
did you inherit your link from your
parents I don't know how to answer you
let's try something else why do the main
shakers wish to trouble our spirits the
people of t'lay may believe there is
only one true god the god of light they
think that all those who do not believe
in their God are in error and they must
learn the truth that if they convert
everyone to their belief then the world
will be saved
saved from what no don't answer you are
sincere but what you are saying makes no
sense if the people think truly what you
have said then they are fools
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]